hi everyone I'm I'm John Benjamin hickey
I am uh going to be the panelist is that
what we're calling me for this uh
wonderful uh postm movie discussion um
about a movie I love very much uh Monica
and these two amazing artists who
brought it to life um I was just
thinking before we came on it's a while
ago that I saw the movie and it has
stayed with me as it will stay with you
guys it's so
when a movie about a family which I
think this is what this movie is about
or or even a play about a family whether
it's like fences August Wilson or or
Long Day's Journey Into Night which Pat
London reasons to go to London yes March
or Andre Andrea's Exquisite uh movie
Monica when you read it you're like well
that's not my family's experience that's
not what I experienced in my family but
because it's rendered so beautifully and
so specifically true to what it is it
does that rare thing that a work of art
does and it becomes Universal and you at
the end of it you're like well that's my
family I maybe we didn't love each other
or hurt each other in the same way these
people did but those feelings are the
same and uh Andrea has achieved a really
rare and Sublime thing how the hell did
you do
it tell us where the thank you for these
beautiful words and thank you for doing
this with us John it's such a pleasure
to be talking to you um well I you
know the desire to to explore and tell
this story really came from a need to to
delve deeper into the complexities of
what means not to being understood not
to being uh seen or being abandoned you
know like I feel like you know anyone
can really relate to to that is
something that is so inherently human
and is something that not only affects
the way we deal with one another but
also our sense of identity and I think
that through as you mentioned you know
through the story of Monica you know we
can recognize ourselves recognize
certain parts of ourselves certain
wounds certain traumas that we all
experience to certain extent and maybe
understand more you know what happened
and and who we are you know and and and
that was really what was behind my my
urgency to to to create this world and
to tell this story with my
collaborators did you have was it
specifically like I did you know trans
people did you have this character in
mind did she come you know out of you
fully out of your imagination how yes I
that's a beautiful question yes I in
fact Monica is inspired by the story
story of a very dear friend of mine uh
someone who I lived with when I first
came to La actually when I was just 20
years old um such a beautiful person
that was also still a very important
part of my life and um I have to say
also that you know it's a character that
I I see myself in too you know like
because of course you know Monica is is
a trans person but I think that as I
said you know we can all recognize
ourselves in her you know but uh it it
does come from someone that I love
deeply yes um Patty uh there oh God no
no no no no no sorry
everyone sorry sorry that's me and I
don't know how to turn that off so just
give me a second God I'm so glad it's
you not me oh boy how to okay hold
on John we love you forgive me don't
worry and it and it was a person I
specifically was it your agent no send
hopefully sending me a script which is
the question was it your husband it was
it was neither it was a person I texted
saying please don't call um py speaking
of Agents uh um you know there's nothing
better than getting a great script how
did this come into your life this
project this well um you know
conventional way uh which is always best
I I had met Andrea at mares and given
him an award alongside Martin Martin
sces and I presented him with best
director at mares film festival and you
know I had met him and knew him and I I
knew he was the kind of director I
wanted to work with but it was several
years later that I get a call from my
wonderful agent and and I know that
sounds oxy ironic but he is he truly is
extraordinary and um and he said Andrea
Boro has this film for you he's just
cast Trace lesette as the lead and I
said oh oh my goodness oh my God that
that that incredible woman from from
transparent and so I said you know he he
sent it to me and I read it
and you know I thought at first am I
just going to like sexy mom or some you
know thankfully it was this really
extraordinary
challenging you know death defying uh
part and so much more it's so much more
than a sexy mom and thank God and
because I've done enough of those but
well maybe not but anyway so I I I but
I'll tell you this John I I said yes to
this faster than any single project I've
ever received it is never lost on me
when you can maybe change the landscape
of our industry and the fact that a
exceptional transgender actress would
have the chance to lead a film to tell
her story to be front and
center and I would be the secondary
character I would be her you know her
backup singer as I joke with you know I
joke that I'll be your backup singer any
day I'll be the wind beneath your wings
darl um and so I I said yes very quickly
um because I
knew how important this film was I did
and and I don't say that
lightly and I also knew it would
be deeply challenging I knew it would I
would be robbed and of of of speech and
body two of the things you know John we
rely on most as actors we we have our
physical presence we have our vocal
presence we have and I had so few of
those available in this part I had
to really rethink how I came to portray
a character in a way I hadn't really
thought before and and I've done a lot
of work and this part took me to a very
very new place in my in my life very new
place it's uh feels that way having been
a lifelong fan friend it's it's a whole
new side of you I mean it's one of those
things where you see two such Sublime
performances and the movie filled with
him the entire ensemble are just pitch
perfect but it really does beg the
question Andrea what came first Monica
or trace and Patty you know like it just
feels like they were just born to play
these parts uh I mean Trace is
giving really a star making performance
and couldn't agree more you know in fact
you know the script was was written
first and then the search for you know
the person who could really embody this
character who I could scul this
character with was a very long one um
one that took over a year I saw over 30
candidates for the role all over the
world wow and uh uh when I mat Trace you
know I I knew that i' found that one
person I could do this with I could
bring this character to life and you
know I was looking for for someone who
could tap into her own truths and reveal
those truths with you know the uttermost
authenticity and uh and that's the great
talent that the trace has uh that is so
touching to so many people who see her
performance
um so yeah that that's how you know my
collaboration with Trey started and then
py was immediately after um you know and
you know I have to say that you know
from a director you know to be you know
constantly you know surprised you know
by you know the the immense talent that
your actors you know reveal day after
day uh is is one of the most
exhilarating things you know and this
happened so many times on the side of
Monica you know like you know when you
know with the you know the raise of an
eyebrow you know watching Patricia for
example you know in in her in her most
intense scenes reveal so much intensity
and complexities I mean who can who can
do that really you know and and to to
had the pleasure and and the honor to to
create this film with these artist
artist you know is is the crowning you
know achievement of a dream really you
you know John every day on that set was
um I remember you know we tend to kind
of it's funny that this movie has stayed
with me more so than so many films I've
done and it's not that I don't love and
admire and and and love the artists I've
worked with in other films but there was
something about the unique unique nature
of this film The Silence in this film
The Quiet in this film that required us
you know we didn't
rehearse trace and I so often you know
I've said this we didn't we didn't have
to discuss what we had for breakfast we
didn't have to talk about how we were
everything that we were that we had
within us as actors as Patty and Trace
and then as Eugenia and Monica that's
what we had to bring every single day we
just had to get on the set and there was
a quiet on the set there was a calm at
times on the set that Andrea you know
he's he's such a Lifeline to us he was a
true Lifeline but we we knew that he
would guide us to the right place and he
is not the the easiest you know he's not
a simple director you know like
the um and he's in he's formidable and
in in the right ways um the set was
always beautiful and and conducive to
bringing the best of us forward and the
right the right moments we had to bring
in this movie we in other movies you
work on it's like you kind of know what
the scene is but often John we were
discovering the scene in the moment in
the day in that sense of where really
what is this scene and it was such an
Awakening every every day on the set
where we were going and talk talk about
that uh that bathtub scene I've seen you
you have many amazing performances o
over your career I I don't know if I've
ever seen you reveal that much of
yourself it it's an incredibly raw
painful uh uh Deep thing to see and what
was that day like and what what do you
do to prepare for a day like that do you
you know tell jokes before do you sneak
a little vodka didn't no um as much as I
like I know I'm just kidding um no no no
but um you know
and John that the scene is one of the
reasons I wanted to do this film because
I loved this rap Roo I loved to have
I I loved that this woman who was living
in a certain kind of old fashion
somewhat conservative environment could
could find you know in the ninth hour of
her life at the very very very end of
her life could find unconditional love
could find could give her child peace
could die with peace you know it it the
scene you know
I think about that scene still now and
it it it's hard for me to really talk
about openly but the truth is
is John mine is always in me because
every single day of my life my parents
gave me unconditional love every single
day of my life they still do and they're
with me I know what that is I know what
it is when your mother or your father
sees you and and loves you truly loves
you sees you for who you are knows who
you are and loves you for exactly what
they see in front of you and I know that
as
Patty and I truly love praise and so the
art and life become one and maybe that's
why it was it wasn't I didn't have to
reach for anything I just had to Simply
bring my truth of my life to
amazing that you drew from a source of
power as opposed to to play such pain
from a source of power that they that
they they Li they live side by side
absolutely love and hurt and um and
Andrea knew this you know I mean he
doesn't meddle and step in and fussy
about he just knew it but but but let me
tell you that from from my my experience
of that day which is uh really something
that is burnt onto my mind in such an
indelible way and not just of mine but
all my collaborators you know because
you know what Patricia and Trace created
for us was you know something that had
such a profound impact on all of us we
were all in tears and you know when that
happens when there is a communal
breathing a communal crying you know
it's such a profound gift of katarsis
and that's something that's a gift for
anyone who can watch the film now you
know it's not just for us to experience
it on that set but anyone and and I am I
am so very grateful to them for for that
because you know the whole film for me
was built around that particular scene
you know that that was actually the
first scene that I wrote and you know
that moment is something really I will
never forget
yeah it's uh it's palpable it's a you
can you can feel everything you're
describing in that scene this is where
my um lack of film intelligence might
might show reveal itself Andrea you shot
this in a very specific and
unique um it's almost like yeah and it's
called something portraiture or
something describe what that is and why
you chose to do it because it's so
deeply successful in in yeah it's a very
unusual aspect ratio is one my Director
of Photography K ismy and I uh created
actually for this film because it's not
one that is used it's a 1.2 to one
aspect ratio and it's a it's a very
square like very portrait like really it
resembles portrait photography and what
it did for us uh which was very very
important uh from the beginning uh it
was that it created you know a sense of
Suffocation and enhanced that
codependence between the characters you
in particular between mother and
daughter and it also allowed us to pay
even more attention to what is left
outside of the frame and uh you know
that is is a dichotomy you know this
like you know between the psychological
and the physical what is inside and what
is outside you know that is like a
revealing theme throughout the narrative
as well and so it was really it it came
from a need to
find the language that could articulate
in the most eloquent way possible you
know our vision and how to penetrate the
complexities of this relationship you
know and you
do yeah go ahead but quickly and that
there was something very freeing for all
of us you know we had to leave vanity at
the door we had to leave a sense of self
ego I never knew what part of my body
was on screen I never
knew I never knew if I was in frame out
of frame it just there there they
there're there was a a a piece that came
about there there was a you had to
relinquish you had to give up all of
what we hold dear as actors you know we
are vain we are grabby we are
egotistical we we we want the light and
this
movie was really a communal effort
really I didn't know when the scene what
part of me was in the scene and it
didn't matter it just didn't matter
sorry just to explain that is that
because because the way you shot it
Andrea the camera is in a it's not
somebody with the steady cam follow you
know no and and but it was also because
of our strategy because we didn't do
coverage you know like most of the
scenes are actually one single shot you
know there are cases which that that you
know it required multiple shots but but
most of the times you know we really
achieved you know this one shot per
scene kind of approach and and and that
you know forces us to you know find the
language and and and work all together
you know from like you know the
composition of the image the use of
sound the performances the set the light
you know in a in a very uh organic way
um so yeah the strategy and the approach
was really dictated the energy on set I
think you know last night I did a
screening Sam Rockwell interviewed me or
did a Q&A with me and his friends and
they were like this is cinema this is
bringing this is cinema this is a this
is an her this is what we are losing in
our in our Cinema language right now
this is what this movie has brought back
and it was really powerful you know and
to hear that from you
know really great actors and and and so
I I don't know I I think that's what
Andrea has is he is he has you know
a a a true voice he doesn't have he
doesn't make a movie he's made his movie
and only his movie it's manifest in your
editing as well I'm Cur because it's you
you were not afraid to linger on a face
an Exquisite face with no words telling
a story just by watching them and was
that in your mind the way you edited it
before you made the movie or did that
become manifest as you watched no no it
was actually in the screen play as well
it was something that I had already
decided I was going to be the approach
but you know that it was because mainly
was because um you know the my interest
was to you know capture the internal
worlds of these characters more than
anything was it was to to to enter their
their thoughts their emotions and uh
that's also why a lot of the film is
really explored and a lot of the
characters are explored not through
dialogue but really by following them
and by staying with them by observing
them and so the the editing and the pace
of the film you know follows that type
of approach of course I mean John so
often these scenes we had to just truly
exist for wow there's no editing to save
us there's no we had to just
exist
for very very long takes it wasn't we we
had to have such an internal life and be
so
present every single day that we were
shooting
because nothing was going to save us did
you
rehearse no no no I actually and you
know I have a different approach with
each actor I work with but I felt that
with both tra and Patricia you know it
was actually best not to do that that
doesn't mean that we didn't spend a lot
of time you know talking
about the scenes and getting to know one
another and and building a sense of
trust which was very important but then
the actual actual rehearsal no we we
didn't we we discovered everything you
know in the moment and I wanted to be
able to capture you know the very first
moment you know that
you know two actors come together you
know on on camera yeah yeah yeah no it
was beautiful and Trace is you know so
alive and present and was there a lot of
conversation you wrote a movie about a
trans person you are not a trans person
but you have them in your life and
clearly had a very very personal
connection and story to tell was there a
lot of conversation between you and
Trace about like who yes you know who
your transperson was who she is and yes
yeah of course of course there were a
lot of conversations and conversations
about representation too and and uh
conversations about uh you know what we
were aware of you know would this role
would mean for so many people you know
and how to best portray that and how to
you know uh give give Justice to you
know the trans community at large as
well you know of course the this was was
something that was a very very important
and crucial part in the creation of the
film as a whole I think it's important
to say that that as much as that is true
what you're saying the movie never feels
political feels like absolutely you know
I have to be honest like that was never
my intention at least that was not one
what motivated me to to go into this
film and to create it and to make it
with all my collaborators but then it
became political after you know because
you know of course you know
representation matters representation
visibility changes the way we think you
know the way uh we we understand things
and and so you know that but but I agree
like you know this film didn't was not
motivated by that was was motivated by a
need to explore humanity and our
relationships and who we are yeah yeah
um I don't know how how what the age uh
range is of the people who are listening
to this so not many people will get this
but I just want to personally say Patty
not since Art Carney and that cat in
Harry and Tanto a 1974 or five movie
have I seen such chemistry between an
actor and an animal please just speak
for just one second well um um that dog
the dog and the the dog in the film is
my beautiful my beautiful isidora Duncan
Clarkson my dog I was supposed to have
two little vulpes remember I was
supposed to have two little dogs and
Andrea it took us a while to raise some
money and Andrea I got to know Andrea he
would whenever I was in LA I had Izzy
with me sometimes and you know and then
when I was here in New York he would
visit and he see Izzy and he fell madly
in love with Izzy and he said B I'm
gonna do a really bad atali I lost
E I said on the you know she's not a
show dog she's like a New York City
dog but she had a quiet temperament
she's was like a fawn you know she's
passed on since then sadly she had an
autoimmune
disease um sadly but um but she was she
was such our mascot you know she
everyone was so deeply in love with her
on the film and uh I gave every single
person remember on the day every single
person on that film when I left the film
I give every single person an icon of
Izzy on you in a shirt a bracelet a hat
because she I wore mine to to our
premiere of the film do you remember or
the cufflinks I gave
yous she she's a beloved creature and
you know that's Andrea he wanted the
truth he wanted he wanted the real thing
and he got it and is he he got the love
it's a good thing you're as good as you
are because she was a scene stealer that
is Yesa don't act with children or
animal exactly I I know there's not a
lot of time left but I remember talking
to you about this before one of the
other extraordinary things about the
world of the movie is your production
design um that that that house which
clearly there was money in that family
at some point maybe there like how did
you build the world of it did you do a
lot of uh scouting yes yes yes yes yes
uh in fact my production designer my
Director of Photography my producers and
I we were uh in we we shot this film in
in Ohio and we scouted the whole region
for over two months you know before
production started and uh you know every
choice was the result
of a very very intense
research methodical research yes so
yeah Kate Aris Mandy our our DP just
shot the whole last season of succession
I mean she's just wow yeah an
exceptional exceptional
exceptional female cinematographer true
artist as well as our production she's
an artist extraordinary and a div Divine
human being so we out yeah and that
production design that location without
getting political in your movie one of
the things that so tells a story it it
tells the backstory of this family
absolutely and also how dangerous the
world is for somebody like Monica like
because you know maybe she's safe enough
in her home although that's very unsafe
in its own way but as soon as she steps
out into the world there's such a sense
of like oh oh God please protect her
like make sure you know it's you you
capture that so beautifully and this is
a very preent thing that's happening in
our world that makes one of the reasons
that makes a movie so important thank
you thank
you thank you I feel like um what else
do we want to talk about guys my phone
hasn't rung again I think we're good you
know I think we've covered everything I
think we're good let's keep it it's such
a hopefully you know I I I think we're
good I think extraordinary my wish is
really that that people can experience
these performances the gifts that uh you
know they have given us really and uh
and and get to know themselves in the
process you know so through party and
Trace and through the rest of the cast
so that's my real wish and the story you
tell yeah it's
Universal um all right well thank you
you go back to your two dogs
John John thank you so much thank you
guys thank you for your we need to go on
that dinner was very hopefully the next
time I'm in New York and everybody else
who's on this call but Andrea's taking
dinner anyway love you Andrea love love
you